the Baltimore Police Department launched
an investigation after body camera video
appears to show an office of planning
evidence this footage was only recently
discovered it seems to show officers
staging evidence earlier this year
during a drug arrest Jeff Pegues is
outside Baltimore Police Headquarters
with how the department is responding
Geoff good morning good morning the
Baltimore Police Department has been
under pressure for years to reform and
part of those reforms have included the
introduction of body cameras but what
the video shows in this case is Rock the
police department across the street as
it responds to allegations that a police
officer actually planted evidence in
body camera video released Wednesday
Baltimore police officers are seen
pulling over a driver in January and
then searching and arresting his alleged
dealer the officers move on to the yard
behind a vacant house looking for the
dealer's stash that's when footage
appears to show one officer of placing
evidence on the ground walking away and
then returning to discover it it's clear
that they manipulated evidence in this
case Debbie Catz Levy is among the
attorneys in the office of the public
defender who first raised concerns about
the possibility of police misconduct in
the first few seconds of the frame the
officer appears to be placing a can on
the ground with suspected narcotics in
it so when you see that what do you
think the first reaction is it's pretty
egregious but the second reaction is
thinking is we have the body cameras
body cameras are now worn by tens of
thousands of police officers across the
country providing an unfiltered look at
interactions between police and the
community but this video highlights the
control officers have over what is being
recorded what did you see in that video
yes I saw the same thing they probably
you saw in everyone in Baltimore and and
probably now across America has seen
Baltimore Police Commissioner Kevin
Davis said the 1,500 body cameras
deployed in his city can help expose
officer misconduct I saw video footage
of
officers apparently placing evidence and
recovering evidence in a way that's
inconsistent with the way police
officers do business mr. Davis is vowed
to get to the bottom of what happened
here the officer or the primary officer
who was involved in this has been
suspended the other two that you see on
the video they're on it administrative
leave
now as far as the man who was arrested
he actually spent seven months in jail
before prosecutors were alerted to that
video and before they dropped the
charges Norah
alright Jeff thank you so much